[Music]
in highway cache news submitted by sip
much a 24/7 oh yeah
drivers stopped on the highway to grab a
hundred and seventy five thousand
dollars in cash that fell out of an
armored truck oh like a dream yes and
did they have to give it back
isn't it marked and like I don't know
who keeps track of that though how did
it fall out of an armored truck isn't
that the point of them being armored is
that they're impenetrable they forgot to
lock it
it's got to go it's an inside job
because the guy inside was probably like
oh like literally inside the truck every
couple of months you see a cache all
over the freeway story really yeah where
it's repeats in the news cycle so that
one we saw where I was like all of the
freeway everyone got out cuz it fell out
or something and the cars are driving
over it so I just like to sort of fly in
the air like the media publications like
man it's a slow day yeah just go to an
armored truck thing again this is a
better news story than most of me
I love this it's like being in one of
those little glass boxes you can only
use your hands you see people in those
you always go [ __ ] you [ __ ]
suck edition let me go in there like
it's so hard yeah you have to grab away
their head that's the rules you can't go
on the floor everybody check your cheese
and do the ticket one they do it's a new
thing I found out at Isaac's fourth
birthday lose your shirt and like walk
like that the execs just want to watch
people are like be fools I do that's
like I'm putting a hundred dollar bill
and then [ __ ] this fishing string did
that to me I found my own apartment and
I thought I walked into a spider web and
then I realized it was so much yeah and
then a dollar and she's a little right
through my face and up into the
apartment above me and I think like a
grown-ass man that lives there - oh my
god
my neighbor is like a goddamn good
millennial I love an idiot being my
competition for idiots it's like you're
wasting so much time yeah all right so
this happened in Atlanta it was on the
to interstate 285 and then so they're
saying that this armored truck the door
just opens and all his money came out
and they're saying that it was about a
hundred and seventy five thousand
dollars that's tight and people that
were driving they were making out they
pulled over oh look at it
[Music]
what idiot is building this and not
exactly wait why are people running to
draw what's happening
they are everyone all the cars apart
yeah all these cars are parked getting
dirty money oh [ __ ] he's like [ __ ]
this [ __ ] down no everybody gets some
are those 20s or hundreds or what
where's the armored truck he just left
you didn't even know maybe not for a
while so wait he's doing always a guy in
the back with a shotgun out so my mom
told me that was a hundred and seventy
thousand dollars on the floor I thought
a suitcase just fell and one person went
and picked it up no it's just free money
like a movie yeah do you think an
armored trucks have leather suitcases
filled with money in their steel it was
the steel one yeah the one where you
[ __ ] put a make shop off the guy's
arm traffic if I was rich and there was
traffic on the freeway I would just take
money and throw it and then watch all
the cars pull over
a helicopter go ahead of them and just
drop money and then you get arrested for
endangering people's lives and then
people are like what the [ __ ] and it
clearly says
fake not real motion picture only let me
guess
the article does not say what type of
bills those work nope just the type of
[ __ ] I'm like however these people
allowed to have jobs that's the most
interesting part of the article and they
always leave it out where'd you get
journalism degrees just that it was
different different what's the
denomination denomination that's what I
pictured too because usually these guys
are picking up or getting change or
whatever from their route well like it's
like a chain and then they're if it's
not related to the bank or whatever if
it's a private armored car company yeah
because like if I had a chain of stores
I would hire them to come and pick up
all the all the extra money or whatever
that needs to be delivered and then it
could have coins it could have all kinds
of [ __ ] but I'm just like how do they
store it I want to know what what it
looks like inside yeah they don't have
dollar signs yeah can you go to jail for
picking up this money yes okay go that's
what they're reporting here is that
they're telling people that if you
picked up this money [ __ ] how you gonna
find me track it I'm telling you it's
like Ocean's eleven they are reviewing
social media videos that have been
posted and looking at license plate
number people have you want their money
man they just do not every goddamn
person everybody that's stealing
yeah yes so they're saying that thanks
[ __ ] a lot a charge the charge would
include theft of loss or mislaid
property and it could be a felony or
misdemeanor depending on the amount that
was taken you know isn't it how many can
you catch do
it's not I used to judge them so hard I
couldn't even get water [ __ ] life
crumbled insect in I just have like a
leaf blower on it too oh yeah so easy
from the outside yeah that's a life baby
exactly right I hope you all learned
something today you did look like a
[ __ ] cat I was embarrassed
all right so we are reporting that
people have been turning in the money ah
there was a loser then that turned in
more than $2,000 because he knew he was
gonna go to jail and he did it we should
be treated like a hero
they took a photo like as this you know
a hero it's a key to the city for the
[ __ ] people don't know he got 10 grand
he returned to exactly that's a smart
guy not the smart move someone else
returned four thousand four hundred and
cash what a square can AT&T wanna
[ __ ] launder that shift at the casino
belly you pick people six people that
turned in that amount ham how honorable
there's still a hundred like $60,000 in
cash out there that they can't get some
guy picked up four grand off of the side
of a freeway and then he's like nope
that's the bank's money are you kidding
me yeah [ __ ] squares in Atlanta yeah
I wonder if they have you know there's
like the numbers and stuff yeah that
serial number that's right and they
track which monies go in these cars no
they don't
so if it comes up and you're at like a
Ralph's or something a big a big sign
goes a wheel ooh
and then the cops show up and it's SWAT
and they [ __ ] arrest your ass like
you have a lot of credit cards you never
have cash on you like it's just like
this modular business yeah all right it
was largely printed money that's the one
that they track right from like the bank
and stuff this is why our country's in
debt too many armored car free money
that's right I think it's because they
keep printing money but empty values
damn I want an armored car like just
because what would you do with it drive
around and make people think I got my
and then they robbed me get g-wagen did
you hear about the shooting that went
down with the Sheriff's Department yeah
so uh why gee I think the rapper and his
crew they gotten a shootout with it's a
Los Angeles Sheriff's Department and
that guy they had a he has a armored
Escalade him and some other dudes
because I forgot something I don't know
the full story but like they someone
shot one of his homies so they went to
go I guess returned that drive-by but
then the cops were there to try to stop
it and so they end up giving a shootout
with the cops but then we have insider
friends that work in the department and
they're showing me pictures of their
cars end up stopping them of course
because they just have infinite force
and they were safer stood the Escalade
they're like oh [ __ ] the bullets aren't
going through yeah is that illegal the
drive will have an armored vehicle huh I
don't think they do not a governmental I
think if you can afford it I mean
they're all I don't like 200 grand 300
grand and start and there's a lot
there's companies that a lot of rappers
have those that's pretty crazy
i watch this one videos I think there's
a company in Nevada that does armored or
bulletproof glass right and in this just
made me want to buy everything from them
they literally just started shooting at
the glass yeah and nothing where did the
bullets do they get some of it gets
stuck or whatever but it doesn't break
and then don't shoot at a normal you
know Clark glass and it just goes
through and but how good it is I'm just
like oh my god and it looks like normal
glass yeah I've seen it would y'all be
nervous to spend this money if you were
someone who found like it is yeah would
you do with it put in a shoebox in your
closet I just would return it I thinks
I'm so scared really yeah hundred
thousand dollars I feel so guilty a
duffel bag I'm turning this event yeah
this does I'm like oh man yeah I'm like
I'm off the radar but a hundred thousand
dollar duffel bag that's some gangster
should go to liquor stores it's $100 by
gum then they give you $99 and rinse and
repeat until you get through four grand
you did no no I put them on the back
mm-hmm I got a job now yeah we're fine
we all should be fine I'm not gonna do
that especially if it's a duffel bag
yeah wouldn't it 100 grand or maybe a
million gangster [ __ ] yeah
it's like yeah you wouldn't pull over
though what if you saw this on the road
you wouldn't look I mean that's that's
that's funny like I got money
ya know none of these people would pull
over no knew that it was illegal to take
it people are going there's [ __ ]
money raining from the Sun I'm picking
this [ __ ] up and then for them to be
like surrett and like you're gonna go to
jail that's just rude it would freak me
out
especially if you didn't see the money
flying out of a armored car and you're
just driving your life how do you know
it didn't come out of the back of a
cartels trunk I'm just an innocent
person who sees money falling on this
guy what do you expect me it's like the
movies yeah people thought there were
leaves and then they're like wait
there's $100 bid $100 smacks me on the
windshield and you're like dude I know
movie right there today your eyes like I
just wished money would fall out of the
sky and then his wife's like what is all
that he was just about to leave
come on we're going to your mom's
[Music]